[Musique]
alors vous l'avez vu vous encore parler
de l'article 64 sûrement pas l'envié qui
lui manquait je me disais que cet
intérêt passionné pour un article qui
somme toute temps à diminuer la
responsabilité de coupables pour fournir
une piste tu prends pas qu'il cherche un
alibi il est normal qu'un juriste
souhaite une application plus rigoureuse
du principe dont s'est inspiré le
législateur les juges ont en outre
souvent des des experts en psychiatrie
qui ne s'embarrasse pas de subtilité oui
maigret hésite
tu veux arrêter avenue de l'opéra dont
plus de vue-là du morne longtemps mais
non seulement le pack les prochains mois
foreman l'écriture à la machine ensuite
j'étais il faut pour cela n'aurait non
plus on pense qu'on peut être les lits
lui n'hésite pas il connaît le chemin du
studio
spécialiste du droit maritime qui habite
rue du cirque
il se sert du papier à lettres le plus
coûteux voyez que c'est lui qui écrit la
lettre lui ou quelqu'un de sa maisonnée
enfin quelqu'un qui a accès à son papier
c'est curieux d'autant plus curieux que
les gens qui écrivent des lettres
anonymes
en général ces serres bout de papier qui
ne puisse pas les trahir
vous allez attendre qu'on réponde à la
danse je ne crois pas
j'espère que ce contexte à ben j'en
éprouve alors l'agent ça tombe bien je
viens de lire le mot fin ah oui à dire
que je sais qu'ils ap il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses avant quand même si
j'étais va je fais comme douloureuse
je le redis à la zac bon alors ce maigre
hésite c'est tout de même un maigret un
petit peu particulier non particulier
c'est que il n'ya pas de crime au départ
c'est à dire que mes graines ne compte
pas sur un crime qui a eu lieu il
enquête parce qu'il a reçu un certain
nombre de lettres là n'a ni queue on le
prévient que quelque chose va se passer
dans une certaine maison une maison de
grande bourgeoisie du quartier du rond
qu'on échange des visées et il va faire
son enquête pour essayer de prévenir ce
crime il sait pas d'ailleurs exactement
si ça sera un crime
et finalement le crime intervient
seulement au tir de liste donne
l'occasion de parts dans cette grande
bourgeoisie qu'on ne voit pas d'habitude
dans les migraines on voit plutôt des
cloud et oui parce que tu pourrais
presque à travers tous émigré qu'on
attendait combien de noms c'est le 28e
patriquin alors tu pourrais prescrire
une étude sociologique de la fin et je
dois dire que depuis depuis les rentes 8
oui évidemment j'ai vu pas mal de milieu
alors mes grèce est un personnage
imagine après tant de fois qu'il a
endossé comptes dont on se débarrasse à
peu mon mais un vêtement vestiaire est
d'ailleurs maintenant je comment dirais
je
je suis un peu adopté si tu veux je
dirais presque je fais partie de la
grande maison et les gardiens de paix
dans la rue m'appelle patron par exemple
ça l'air de rien mais est ce qu'au moins
deux veaux de ne pas avoir de contrat
pour toi à moi non je vais te raconter
une histoire très drôle c'est que le 1er
mai grecs on avait fait baisser s'il est
morte et on tournait à cheville et bien
entendu il y avait une scène de
cimetière qui dit bien entendu parce que
souvent dans les grillades et celle de
cimetière et barma voulait la faire très
tôt le matin pour avoir l'ambiance très
ciblée non et alors je me trouvais à une
veillée sur les quais la mort
et puis je sais pas comment je me
débrouille le l'assistant avait donné un
épi derrère curieux je me trouvant pas
dans un sens interdit
et puis j'essaie de passer à un feu
orange qui passent au rouge
je pense vraiment à sa trame en
coulisses il plaît d'agents de police et
c4 qui gaine trouvait en fait
vous êtes jeanrichard
oui
abba depuis le temps qu avec ma femme
monique il faut qu là il veut voir
passer il a failli écrire par été pour
no border bonnes opinions
aucun sujet doublement ne plaît pas aux
criminels
j'ignore tout le droit d'arrêter on
verra